thank you very much I pistols for the
introduction and I'd like to thank you
and the organizers for inviting me to to
speak here today it's been a it's going
to know truly a exciting symposium so
far can we lower the lights a little bit
so demanding yeah it's leaking yeah
that's that's much better okay so we're
going to talk about is programming
nanoscale structure using DNA based
information I always start my talk with
this slide so that we're all on the same
page okay now everybody in this room
knows the DNA is a genetic material of
all the organs have shown here the
plants the animals and the people and
for the rest of the hour I want you to
forget that okay we're not talking about
DNA is genetic material we're talking
about DNA the molecule and the things we
can do with it and the information that
it contains this is the configuration of
human bones with which we're all
familiar but if you do what the VOE the
artist did here and strip the flesh from
these bones well perhaps there's no
really compelling reason to organize
them in this fashion so for example this
is a chandelier in the cemetery of the
capuchin monastery in Rome if you look
closely at you'll see that it too is
made of bones of effect the bones of the
deceased members of that particular
religious order and it sort of sets the
theme what we're going to talk about
taking a natural material and making an
unnatural object from it now bones are
fascinating but we don't work with bones
we work with the smaller kill over here
DNA
everybody who's been to kindergarten
since about nineteen sixty is familiar
with this molecule some of us in this
room didn't quite make that cut
including myself so let me just review a
few features of the molecule everybody
everybody I think knows the DNA double
helix you might not be aware that the
two strands have a chemical polarity or
actually oriented in opposite directions
so this Pentagon is pointing down but
the one opposite it is pointing up for
example DNA is and then a scale object
its diameter is 20 angstroms 2
nanometers roughly and its helical
repeat is about three and a half
nanometers the spacing between the base
units along the helix axis directions
about 3.4 angstroms this formed with
which we are most familiar is called be
DNA by this is a right-handed helix if
you look at the entrance to the room
you'll see that it was drawn in mirror
image up and the business end of DNA is
not the backbone really it's these two
sets of famous watching creek base pairs
a that hydrogen bonds with t so those
are weak bonds with two hydrogen bonds
and g that pairs to see with three so
it's a little stronger base pair now if
i want to make something interesting at
a DNA there's a problem with the
molecule i'm showing here because the
helix axis is linear now when i say
linear I don't mean linear in the
geometric sense of being a straight line
I mean linear in the topological sense
of being on branch so that basically you
tack lines together what you make our
longer lines since it's not entirely
rigid you know you might make a good
circle I was mentioned yesterday or on a
good day and not or a cat named but you
can't make things that are really highly
interesting
to me so we have a solution to that and
what it is is the following up with it's
called reciprocal exchange and I call it
here it we stole this from biology so I
call it a bio kleptocratic alyna sense
that we do it on paper we don't actually
do it in the laboratory we do what the
paper tells us to do so it's a Sheila
I'm talking about here here's a blue
strand here's a red strand following
reciprocal exchange don't have a red
blue and a blue red string now if we
look at that in the context of being a
double helix all right here to double
helix ease if I do that operation at
this point and color the strands that
I've done it to green we start off over
here we cross over and we go down to the
other side and the same thing with the
other strand now I did that over here
between two strands whose polarity is
the same but remember they're two
different directions so i can do it
between strands with polarity is not the
same if i do that as I do on the bottom
here I go down like this crossover and
come back up like that and the other one
looks like this now these two molecules
are really just different shapes of
exactly the same molecule if I flip this
helix and firend I'll get this structure
but later you'll see that if we do this
operation more than ones who really
create different topological species an
easier way to look at this molecule
shown over here when you draw the four
stranded molecule as it just like a
crossroads in a highway and what I'm
showing here are four different strands
the red one the green rent one the
magenta and the cyan and if we put them
together in this pot they will associate
to create this branch point which which
is key to everything we do the algorithm
for by which we do this is quite old now
over 30 years and what we do basically
is divided up every one of these strands
into a series of overlapping short
elements in this case tetramers so each
of these is a 16 work so that means we'd
have
13 overlapping tech rumors and we insist
that those each be unique and we insist
that those going around a corner like
this not have their watson-crick
compliment present so you'll find no t
CAG contiguously with the right polarity
in this molecule meaning that in this is
a very simple case but we do this for
more complicated molecules this things
that each of these octamer 'he's is
competing only with tech rumors so this
atg couldn't principle be over there but
that isn't what what we see happening in
around when we do the experiment and we
also insist that there be no symmetry no
two-fold symmetry around the branch
point that leads to instabilities in
addition to that forearm Junction that
we started studying because it's a an
intermediate it was analog on
intermediate and genetic recombination
you can make branch junctions with more
arms five arms and six arms and Yin Lee
Wong in the lab reported those in 1991
eight arms and 12 arms even were
reported by sheng wang about six years
ago but what i want to do is go back to
the fall of nineteen eighty in Taylor
more detailed story Cristo started
telling when I went over the campus pub
to think about the six-armed Junction
and when I walked into the bar I was
thinking about this thing is having this
kind of snowflake six-fold planar
symmetry but in fact while I was there I
thought of this would cut of Escher's
called called depth and I realized that
each of these fish was in fact
topologically similar isomorphous with
the lips of six armed Junction start in
the middle is a head and a tail top fin
the bottom fin right Finn
and the fish and the left fin but far
more importantly to me at that instant
was the fact that these guys are
organized like the molecules in a
molecular crystal periodic arrangement
front to back periodic top to bottom
periodic left and right now the reason
this was so interesting to me at the
time was that I had been hired as a
structural biologist crave the current
word for crystallographer and I was my
job to do the crystal structures of
various biological molecules and by this
point in my life which was started by
fourth of five probationary years I had
managed to crystallize nothing of any
interest to myself or anybody else and I
was facing a sort of fatal progression
of no crystals no crystallography no
crystallographer and
and you know it occurred to me that a
scheme like this might say myself I
could align molecules using some kind of
DNA like interaction so you know
although Usher was it was in charge of
all little pen strokes or whatever in
this lid cut in fact I need to use a
natural interaction and the one that I
that I used was you know had already
been used for extensively by genetic
engineers and this is sticky ended
cohesion so here I've unwanted a couple
of double helix ease to show you a
sequence and this strands little longer
than this one this strands so longer
than this one so these overhangs are
called sticky ends if the overhangs
themselves a complementary then these
two double helixes watch to cohere to
form a single unit and if you want if
there's a phosphate on the five prime
end you can actually like eight them to
being covalent molecules and that's one
half of the story of sticky and the
other half is shown over here the
crystal structure that hong cho chu and
lat and our lab reported or 15 years ago
and it consists of an infinite helix of
DNA within the crystal it's but it's got
a repeat of of 10 nucleotides shown here
and then another there and this is the
sticky end this is what's holding it
together the important thing here is
that the DNA over here the DNA over here
is absolutely identical to itself this
is upside down of course from that
because it's a half turn away but
basically it's all the same be DNA
structure that I showed you in that
early slide so that means that not only
you know doing heck no affinity we know
structure we know if we know the
coordinates of these atoms we know the
coordinates of these atoms I mean we in
solution we might not know them terribly
far out but I say outside of the
building but at least locally we know
what where these atoms are going to be
so that we have both affinity and
structure on a predictive basis when we
work with things held together
by sticky and in cohesion so the we've
done is basically combine these two
notions branch DNA and sticky and
cohesion so here is a sticky and a its
complement a prime being its complement
be Prime and here I'm just showing them
come together to form this little
quadrilateral object here but so that's
an object but you can see there are a
lot of sticky ins on the outside so this
could in fact form a lattice and later
I'll show you some nano mechanical
devices we can also make for our
laboratory the things that we want to do
with this are basically architectural
control and scaffolding attacking the
macromolecular crystallization problem
and some aspects of DNA based
computation and then electronics
organization for our devices we're
interested in nanorobotics a nano
fabrication I don't have time today to
talk about right self replicable systems
which we're also working on this just
shows you know what we're talking about
with the crystallization problem this is
how all crystals are made so what we do
is we get the guest conditions and we
set up crystals there's an optional step
in the middle for those so inclined and
then we look to see if we have crystals
if the answer is yes well you can go off
into crystallography if you go to my web
page which I will show you the URL of at
the end you'll see that this is actually
the second version of this slide in the
first version which is there I forgot
that this branch existed
and it's a good so rare for us so
basically then you know you have your
choice you can go through your middle
your inner loop here or you can go back
through the outer loop here but this
sort of minimal feedback from failure
over here to knowing what to do the next
time around you know it just didn't work
that's all you really know so our
suggestion is basically to make a box
and that's shown here in magenta the Box
being DNA little thing sticking out our
sticky ends and the idea is to have that
box act as a host for macromolecular
guests we aren't quite at that stage yet
for macromolecules but i'll tell you
about about how we do know how to make
the boxes now Makoto Fujita has recently
reported on a small molecule scale being
able to achieve our complete goal here
but only for small molecules another
thing you can imagine doing is using
this same type of system for organizing
nanoelectronics so here are the Aqua
things or DNA branch junctions pendant
from them is something that would behave
functionally as a molecular wire the
idea is these things would be organized
by the DNA we and many many of the
groups are now working on this approach
why do we want to use DNA for this given
you know given these goals and the short
answer is that nucleic acid sequences
can be programmed and synthesized
leading to the information based
structure dynamic and arguably catalytic
chemistry i'm not going to is my
propaganda slide and i'm not going to
subject you to it but by and large the
two key points here are predictable
interaction intermolecular interactions
with sticky ends we discussed and also
since about nineteen ninety-five we've
been able to design shapes by selecting
sequences we couldn't do that earlier
one of the things you have to keep in
mind when you work with the with DNA is
the topology matters it's not it's not a
problem it's something that can actually
be your friend but you've got to be
aware of it so for example here these
are slightly larger versions that
quadrilateral I showed you and if you
separate the vertices by two turns of
DNA and
number of half turns then you get a
chainmail like structures there's a red
link a red loop linked twice to those
two turns to a blue loop to a red loop
to a bloop and so forth if you switch
that to a turn and a half now you have
blue strands going this way and red
strand is going this way in an
interwoven structure you just have to
keep the topology of mine when you work
with it we have an intellectual goal
here sure and that's controlling the
structure of matter in 3d the highest
extent possible to acrylic
crystallographer like myself that means
the best resolution so is to understand
the connection between the molecular and
macroscopic scales Fineman was well
known for saying you know what I cannot
create I do not understand but the
inverse isn't necessarily true we've
made many things that we don't
understand how I am so not the only
thing with that introduction let me just
talk about some of the things we've done
so we started off making polyhedral cat
names this is in the era before we can
control geometry we could only control
topology and the first thing that was
made was made by a young who H n cube
like molecule in a truncated octahedron
molecule made by you and song and then
again both of these were strictly
topological instructions we don't know
their actual shapes so the cube like
molecule had two turns from vertex to
vertex so this is like a chainmail thing
it's just a hexa can't name the front
face corresponds to the cyclic single
red strand here and each face
corresponds to some cyclic strand and
the red strand is linked twice to the
green the cyan the magenta the dark
boost transit blanket and only
indirectly linked to the yellow strand
at the rear using a solid support based
methodology you and sung some years
later made a truncated octahedron this
is a 14 cat name
of the same fundamental notion and and
like like that we were unable to extend
this to form the macromolecular zeolite
structure that we'd hope to make with it
so then we backed off a little bit for
making more complex structures and
trying to make simple things that would
be robust this slide shows I a slide i
took some years after the slide the
caption management monastery this is in
the catacombs in Paris you can see we
have a really beautiful little 2d array
here of the ends of a six little femurs
and his thigh bones and we're now going
to time to make two dimensional arrays
to start with you know hopefully with
the kind without the kind of defects
that you can see on this particular
slide so we're going to construct to a
crystal and arrays and if the components
for that have to have predictable
interactions and predictable local
product structures we've discussed with
the sticky ends but the last thing they
also have to have a structural integrity
it's a fancy way for so saying that
these molecules have to be sort of stiff
and rigid and this is not a bad dynamic
structural model for a simple branch
Junction so marshmallow that's have been
impaled by uncooked rotini ok so the
uncooked pasta are very very stiff but
the marshmallow itself is floppy so you
know you don't have much controlling the
angles in between these guys if you look
closely at rotini in the western
hemisphere you see in fact that they're
all right-handed double helix ease in
Europe you can find them with both
chirality
to solve this problem what we've done is
go back to our motifs generation
protocol and now we do to reciprocal
exchange instead of one so we make
something with to helix axes that are
coplanar and we can do that either in
the system where the the strands that
are exchanging have the same polarity or
the opposite polarity it turns out that
these are much better behaved so now
we're going to stay below this line here
you can see that they are different
there's four strands here to register
blues here they're five strands of two
Reds to sorry to register greens here to
2 Reds to greens and a blue in the
middle we can extend this as far as we
want to make what we call TX molecules
these RDX molecules for double and
triple and so forth hela sees the first
thing that we did of this sort was to DD
x rays and we made this work with Eric
Winfrey of Caltech from New Lisa Windsor
my lad did the following experiment
where they took 2 DX molecules one of
which had an extra feature on it and put
them together to form a two dimensional
lattice so the sticky ends here are
shown geometrically so this complements
that is to hear this too there and it
still there so you get a nice to the
lattice on paper and this thing this
extra feature is coming out of the
screen at you more importantly it's
coming out of this plane at the tip of
an atomic force microscope so you should
see a stripe like feature and when you
look in the AFM you see this stripe like
feature and we and I should mention that
these guys are 16 nanometers in size so
the separation of the stripes should be
32 nanometers do you see something
that's roughly 32 nanometers if you do a
control experiment you take four of
these guys of the same dimension now we
should see something like a 64
nanometers
right and indeed we do when we look at
this zoom so those it's really nice to
be able to make two dimensional
molecules but what we really are
interested in here in terms of making
crystals is three-dimensional crystals
and this is work that was that was done
and report just a couple of years ago
jianping Zheng is actually in the
audience which is very very nice and
gents Berta and Yi Chen who was of
Purdue and with a student of chengdu mao
from purdue who was chengdu his wife
former student and then Tonglong russia
Sean Pam constantino from my lab see
Steve Janelle was from argon and we
collected diffraction data NSLs and that
are gone as well so the motifs that we
used was originated by chengda and this
is a four turn version of the molecule
that he first made and it's kind of an
over-under over-under over-under DNA
motif it's pretty robust and with that
motif we should expect to see
rhombohedral symmetry which we do we can
predict the cell edges which we also do
also see but the resolution here is not
so good it's about 10 angstroms and
that's not really acceptable for x-ray
work so this just shows the motif this
is a picture Cheng did took when he was
out jogging one morning and you can see
it's over under over under and so forth
and
this is somewhere in the vicinity of
Phoenix gen ping figured out that we
would probably do better on resolution
if we shorten each of the different
edges of the triangles and we also
scimitar eyes them so at this sticky end
and this sticky end the sticky ones are
the same so this nick has been sort of
it's over two-thirds of a nick in each
of these three positions this is
arguably the most exciting slide for me
that I've ever shown an audience because
these crystals are macroscopic okay I
don't know if you can see the scale bars
and all these guys but it's the 200
microns you can see these crystals with
your naked eye I was of course under a
microscope and we know where every atom
is in these crystals before we did the
crystal structure but however I am an
artist crystallographers we made my own
a derivative this thing and determine
the structure by singling almost
dispersion methods and this just shows
the structure of the molecules in front
of the screen the plaintiff screen
behind in front in the plane behind and
so forth this slide shows how all of the
triangles are connected to each other
through a sticky end at this position in
the crystal and I should point out this
is about four angstrom data collected at
ApS in Oregon it was five angstroms in
at nsl us they have more powerful source
in Chicago this shows the environment of
a single one of these triangles so that
you can see that it's a kind of six
connected lattice so we have we go from
the rear in this red direction to the
front and from the rear and the green
direction of the front and the same in
the yellow direction in this case so you
can see how the letters organize them at
these three different directions do
indeed span three space another
selection of triangles shows that they
all of their centers can be placed at
the vertices of a rhombohedral so the
red one is that the rear vertex of the
rhombohedral it's connected to three
yellow triangles that are a little
closer to ease to each us to us and then
each of them is connected to these three
green triangles they're closer to us we
left out the other red one flanking the
front vertex this is for just just for
clarity this is a drawing by Dave good
cell of that same arrangement the far
rear one the three that are closer to us
the three closer to us yet but now you
can see it in the context of the crystal
structure you can see how this
arrangement goes on forever this is a
slide now getting somewhat old but it's
the structure I just showed you is the
one on the top line here but in fact
we've been able to do this with two
turns three turns and four turns on each
of the edges and we get predictable cell
dimensions in every case and we get a
cavity whose size is increasing as the
edge length increases but unfortunately
the resolution decreases as the edge
lengths get longer and we're working on
that problem now show you some of our in
the first attempts at that
shortly this is a movie just to show you
make you make you a little more at home
with this motif this is the four turn
triangle rather than a two turned right
we've done them all and this just shows
you how this thing how eight of these
guys are able to come together to form
the rhombohedral there's the eighth one
coming in and capping the arrangement
and you can you can see how this
structure does does fill three space in
it so it's a real polyhedron there the
other thing that should be clear here is
these are eight triangles coming
together to formally rhombohedral but in
fact in the crystal we have 50 trillion
of them coming together to form the
macroscopic object one of the nice
things about being able to control the
intermolecular interactions to be able
to self-assemble our crystals as opposed
to simply putting them in a pot and
hoping something comes out is that we
can control what's in there so this is
an example where we put two molecules in
the crystallographic repeat work done by
Tonglong Rajesh are you in spirit of gin
ping and kingdom mal and this shows the
same rhombohedral where every edge is
flanked by a red and a green triangle
rather than just triangles are the same
flavor so these are two different
flavors of triangle and the red degree
in just arbitrary drying colors is a
space-filling model is a little clearer
and you can see that it consists of two
that the rhombohedral consists of two
intersecting tetrahedra the tetrahedron
regular because the rhombohedral not a
queue
ruji shah was able to take advantage of
these two different types of molecules
in the crystal and to color the crystal
so he took a pink dye called cy3 and he
attached it to the a molecule to be
molecular both they got pink crystals he
took a blue dye and did the same thing a
molecule B molecular both and got a blue
crystal and then he attached in either
order a and B or B na to the molecules
and he was able to make a purple crystal
so we can actually control a macroscopic
properties of the crystals by just
directly now we were able to get some
nanocrystals at LC ls-dyna Stanford here
to diffract a little better than four
anxious we were also able to do this
work at do this at Brookhaven but this
just showed that we could do it in
crystals that were not frozen as most
samples are this is done by Ernest under
saccharine and you ohio high n and elma
schlichting petra from Henry Chapman
were involved in about 30 other people
it's a huge team people when we collect
nanocrystal data down there and
this aqua circling on what you can see
it is the four angstrom ring and I don't
know what you can see if it's our spots
out here and so forth in this case and
also by changing the context we were
able to get down to three angstrom
resolution NSLs it was the same group of
people with an m1 gents andrew g were
involved and this is that 3.4 angstrom
spacing that i pointed out to you on the
early DNA slide and there are spots well
beyond that ring again this is actually
a double spot if you blow it up so you
can see it another one out here I get
that may be an artifact so if we shorten
the sticky ends and put phosphates on
all of the arms of the triangle we can
get two down to about three angstroms a
diffraction and we're working to do
better and we think we may know how to
do that let me briefly talk to you about
going from jeans to machines making
animal mechanical devices the first
devices that we made were shapeshifters
this is an example of shape-shifting
this is Daphne turning herself into a
laurel tree to escape the attentions
over here of Apollo but the first one
was a bz device made by Chengdu Mao a
long time ago back in the last century
in fact which consists of a DX molecule
a DX molecule and they're joined by a
shaft shown in yellow here of a DNA that
is capable of undergoing a transition
known as the bz transition that's a
right-handed to left-handed DNA
structure we're not taking anything from
mirror planes it's just a different
conformation and the way you trigger
that is by the addition of cobalt hexa
me and as you can see that this yellow
stuff looks different from that which is
conventional structure what we have over
here after that's happened is that this
domain is now
the top of this long shaft rather than
on the bottom we could show that by a
fret pair of dies I don't like that
device very much because it doesn't take
advantage of the programmability of DNA
which I regard as its major strength so
how you n the lab built a
sequence-dependent device and that was
based on yet another motif that we
should talk about so now we're going to
be on the upper half of this slide and
everywhere one of these points faces
another point there and there there and
there there there there and there we're
going to perform a crossover operation
we do that we're going to make something
called a px molecule the perineum across
over this is a better picture of px and
what looks like is a turn and a half of
red double helix wrapped around a turn
and a half of blue double helix it's a
little more subtle than that if you look
closely you'll see there's actually
pairs between these the Reds and the
Blues in certain places if we eliminate
these crossovers we get this structure
we call JX structure and this gives us
only a term of structure so these are
the basis for the two different
structures of turn and a half different
a half-turn different from this and the
way in which we convert them is we take
the registrant and we break it and
insert the screen strand and we take the
blue strand we break it and insert this
strand so you can get the green strands
out and put the yellow strands in we can
ship switch of the
the shapes in the states of these
molecules and this is a sequence
dependent area we can make many
different sequences there so that the
way in which we do that is by technique
worked out by Bernie jerky when he was
at Bell these little horizontal pieces
of green or yellow over here represent
DNA that's simply sticking out into the
solution about eight nucleotides and
Bernie called a toehold if you throw in
the complete complement to the screen
strand including the toehold it'll sit
down over here and we'll branch my
greatest way up to here and pull out the
green strand that's holding it together
that leaves you with a naked frame you
can put in the other guy and you just
keep going around the clock like that
the way how it showed this by afm so you
can actually see it was to take a series
of these devices and use them to connect
some trapezoidal half hexagons that he
had lying around the drawer and in the
green strand state they're all parallel
and in the yellow strand state there's a
zigzag structure here and this just
shows AFM of successive cycles of
parallel zigzag parallel and zigzag one
other type of device I want to talk
about is a walker this is going to be a
DNA walking biped designed and built by
bill Sherman in the lab and it walks
like an inchworm so it has a little
sidewalk it works it walks on which is a
little TX molecule and it can walk
either this way or that way but this
foot is always go in front of this foot
but blocks both ways and this is a movie
just showing you how it works for using
a yorkie chemistry it's held down on the
sidewalk like that we pull it out
put it in those strategies hold it down
here after its flopped around for a
while we released a hind leg and we put
this one also in over here and I can
walk in both directions I want before I
go on to sort of the final thing we
doubt this is a meeting of symposium
devotes computer scientist so I just
mentioned a few of the things that
happen in DNA based computation which is
related to what we've done in some
respects this area was experimentally
initiated by Len adelman is Hamiltonian
path experiment almost 20 years ago now
and this just sort of shows the
experiment that he did so I've just
taken cities around the globe kido New
York Paris Johannesburg alembert or
Shanghai and Melbourne and what's got
what we're going to do is we have a
series and in complete series of routes
between them and this is how the
Hamiltonian path problem is set up and
what we need to do is to be able to find
an initial city in this case we're going
to go from Quito to Shanghai and we're
going to do that through this purple
route so actually if this turns out to
be the right answer going through the
magenta route to olin but tore down to
Johannesburg up to New York Paris
Melbourne and Shanghai the way that Len
did this experiment was to represent
each city with a 20 more of DNA and each
of these cities had a phosphate on its
end enabling the ligation reaction to
occur each route was represented by the
compliment so the first ten nucleotides
were sort of the first thing of a city
in the last ten nucleotides of the last
one so if the roots were the compliments
to
the last name of the first city and the
first name of the last city so they were
kind of catalysts and they were holding
these guys together and then they could
get ligated so he tossed everything in a
pot together and those phosphorylated
cities and the catalysts and then he
allowed ligation to take place and then
he just did a selection the targets were
all 140 murs and so he ran the products
on a gel and just threw out everything
that wasn't 140 140 we're being seven
cities x 20 nucleotides he idea was to
start in kyoto and end in shanghai so he
did the PCR reaction with which has
primers and he just used keto and
Shanghai as the primary for the
conference of them and then he just
selected all the intermediate cities by
selecting for them on magnetic beads now
so this is an idea that you know people
got very excited about it hasn't gone
all that far in this direction another
route that I think is ultimately going
to be more potent regarding computation
and logic and DNA is shown over here
which an algorithmic assembly this is a
cumulative xor calculation that was done
by Ching de mal from my lab Tama being
and John right at Duke and just
introduced this these are Wang tiles
most of this audience is probably more
familiar with them than I am basically
we've got a bunch of squares here that I
have a series of different colored edges
and these are supposed to self-assemble
according to the local rule that
edges of the same color but one another
and what you can see this is actually a
calculation the way it works is this is
a supposed to represent the summation of
five plus nine coming to 14 so the
calculation starts off over here go runs
down over the down this diagonal until
it meets this pathway this tile is then
inserted to fit sit over there that
changes the direction coming over here
when it meets the nine thing then it
comes up here to the 14 tile so this and
you know this this type of self-assembly
apparently is emulates the operation
with Turing machine now you can think of
this as a calculation you could think of
it as an algorithmic assembly this is
six long and 14 across forget to last
row column and if I were going to make
this pattern using the serve the
methodology I was talking about it would
take 84 tiles but in fact it wouldn't
take 84 tiles it would only take to make
exactly this pattern 23 tiles these 16
plus these would all have to be unique
over here and this is an algorithmic
style of assembly and and that notion
was originally promulgated by Eric
Winfrey and you know his idea was very
simple to take the kind of branch DNA
molecules with sticky ends that we were
using in our system and have them
emulate
Wang tiles so in the example i'm going
to show you which is a one dimensional
example we're just going to do
cumulative XOXOX or is probably all of
you know is just a simple logic gate if
the inputs are the same 0 and 0 1 0 1
you get zeros if they're different you
get one and we're going to accumulate of
XOR which means we just daisy chain
these for about four and the tile that
we're going to use is this TX tile that
has this red reporter stranded it that
becomes important as we as we go on to
do the calculation now I showed you this
slide earlier this is our for tile
two-dimensional assembly now what
happened here was that the correct tiles
say this red tile over here was
competing against incorrect tiles for
its slot ok so you the right one never
had much trouble finding its right slot
and there were no errors that we've the
ever detected in these arrays so it's
correct tiles campaign against incorrect
house now the tiles we're going to use
in the XOR calculation and pretty much
any algorithmic assembly don't have that
character so the tile is used here we're
in put tiles over here so these business
either one or zero these are initiators
you'll see how that works the moment but
these are the calculation tiles the four
different possible input 0 and 0 1 and 1
1 and 0 0 and 1 and those numbers are
based on the sticky end which I'm
showing you again geometrically and if
you look over here this is a 1 over he
looks to the correct tile is this tile
ok the one in one tile but we have a 1
over here we also have a one over here
of exactly the same structure and on the
other end we have this is the one over
here we have this one over here there so
that the correct I'll this one is
competing against two half correct tiles
that's much more difficult chemist
all right now yet we've got this to work
pretty well here so what you're going to
see here this is the assembly we have
longer sticky ends on the input tiles of
the initiators and then that creates a
slot for this first tile so it's one and
then for the second position it's 1 & 0
so we'll get another one in there one on
one will give us a zero zero and zero
give us another zero so this thing
actually works to get the answer out we
like eight this red string that goes all
the way out here so it's actually four
tiles out here and floor tiles out here
and the initiators they're all connected
and then there if it's a one it's got a
restriction site for one enzyme and a
zero for a different enzyme then we can
just read the answer off the gel 1100
just like I just told you now 2d
algorithmic assembly was eventually done
but by Winfrey and his colleagues Paul
Rodman and Nick papadakis but it wasn't
that it was done but it wasn't really
successful you can see all these little
red x's and so forth where they made a
serpent's key triangle but there are a
number of errors there for exactly the
reasons that I was telling you about
we've tried to address that problem
shown here by inserting devices to
program a pattern and this is work done
by hangzhou goo and Ji Joe in my lab so
the ideal is the following we would sink
these two devices into an array so the
array is down here and depending on how
we program these guys we remember it's
that same JX PX device i showed you
before we would have either green on top
dark brown on the bottom of a gent on
top blue on the bottom or some other
combination so here we have PX + PX so
that's tile one would go in howto would
go into the j x JX the
J xpx would give us tile three in the PX
j because we give us now for what we
sank them into was what's known as DNA
origami this is something Paul Rodman
coming up with in two thousand and five
or six and it consists of a huge long
strand 7,500 nucleotides 7,500 units
that is designed to form a given shape
in this case a hexagon with two right
angles and it's held in shape by would
have called these little staple strands
over here here's a larger version of
that and it's it works remarkably well
so you just throw in these two about 200
of these little strands in with this
long strand and you get the shape you
wanted so Paul was well known for making
a square a rectangle a star he was best
known for making a smiley face of DNA
and a couple of other structures as well
so we used that same device to make this
particular origami with two slots in it
you can see a notch in the thing so we
know which way is up and then we added
in those two devices which could be
programmed to be either in the PX state
of JX state in both cases there are four
possible things that we could capture
depending on the four different states
in which we put these two devices a
triangle pointing up or triangle put
down up a double diamond or a linear
feature
and this is an example of the triangle
pointing down this is the triangle
pointing up this is the diamond and this
is a linear linear features so the
question is how do you know I'm not
cherry picking all right how do you know
I just didn't say okay got one of those
put it on the on the AFM picture the
answer is we went through an algorithm
where protocol we were actually able to
figure out what to do to get the right
answer every time and it was a fun it
would add a proper possible capture
molecule and what happened we found was
the correct molecules bound half correct
molecules also bound but at least we'd
have to rewrite the incorrect molecules
so we got rid of one third of the wrong
molecules we would then the heat and add
the next molecule and what what happened
is the correct molecules will displace
the half correct molecules and the
correct molecules were not displaced by
either half correct during correct
molecules so in fact the system actually
work and we can repeat this for all
species and get the right answers and
one other thing i want to show you about
DNA computation from our lab was work
done by Gong Wu with the help of Natasha
agent oscar where we saw the little
graph theory problems a three-color
ability issue so here's a little graph
and the question is is this three
colorable can you color each of the
vertices in such a way that no edge is
linked by the same color well this is
the answer over here you can see it when
DNA so we have branch junctions in each
of the positions of these guys but of
course what we did is we programmed each
of the junctions so there wasn't just a
red one in this position there was also
a blue one and a green one that we could
have gone in here each edge consisted of
a long section that sort of said okay
I'm red and I'm this particular Junction
and
then in the middle it said I'm right
around blue in the middle and then I'm
this particular Junction so I talked to
my maid over here am i made over here or
here and then if we had the same color
we would create a restriction site that
could be cleaved by a restriction enzyme
so here was the correct answer showing
the three color ability of the graph and
here what is what happened we only
through it or fix to you fixed two
vertices always this one that one and we
threw in only one other color and we and
then two other colors and then all three
and then on this oops come on come back
here we go on this gel we could see that
when we threw in the restriction enzymes
we destroyed the one with one color we
destroyed only two colors but this one
remained it's very faint because they're
81 different strains there are only one
set of those actually survived but if it
did work so we were able to establish
the three color ability of this graph
now I want to go back to DNA nanotech
and just talk about one last story which
is combining multiple components this is
a macroscopic version of combining
multiple components in a nanomechanical
in a mechanical device so this is a self
opening umbrella and the way it works is
you start off with rain and that causes
a sponge to expand when it gets wet that
hits the lever that hits the that moves
the thumb down to hit the striker wheel
that then lights the candle the candle
boils the water in the kettle when the
kettle is boiling the whistle blows when
the whistle blows a monkey jumps onto
the trapeze he swings back and forth and
that cuts the string that holds this
helium filled balloon in place and it
rises opening the door to this cage and
this little bird attached to every one
of the ribs of the umbrella and they fly
in different directions and that opens
the umbrella and keeps the guy dry now
this is a little more efficient than the
things we've been able to do so far but
we're still we're still we're still
working on that all right what we have
done is make a proximity-based
programmable
nanoscale assembly line work done by
hangzhou goo and Ji show again the
components that we're going to combine
our pxj x2 cassette sort of like what
we're used to from their other work a
clocked walker but this is going to be a
somersaulting walker not an inchworm
nanoparticles and DNA origami with which
you're already familiar so this is an
assembly line from about 90 years ago
and it's in Detroit and what they're
doing is they're making a car so there
are three key components here this
director will assembly the most
important thing the worker who knows
what he's doing is going to attach
something to this chassis rolling
through the assembly line we have a
conveyor system here that's going to
roll us along and then we have a
framework the factory that's going to
hold everything in place in a reference
system so what we're going to do is
we're going to replace the assembler
with a pxj x2 cassette it's programmable
interest a shin conveyor is going to be
our trigonal Walker it's just could be a
tense every triangle we did the crystal
structure of a little longer arms and
the framework will be a DNA origami so
this shows the Assembly of a system
where we're going to add every possible
component to this potential chassis ie
this Walker what you see in this line
and schematic and this row Instamatic is
shown over here in afm so we have three
stations where we can add things a 5
nanometer particle a pair of couple 5
nanometer particles or a 10 nanometer
particle and right now all three of
those are in the off position as we the
first step will change the state of this
one to the on position and by proximity
I'll show you how it works later we
actually add the fine a meter particle
over here and you can see how this is
moved down then we take a half step and
a whole step to position ourselves under
the second per second station then we'll
do the same thing will change the state
of this guy and
add the second one the purified I'm your
particles you can see that over here
then we're going to take a half step on
a whole step in position ourselves on to
the third station and then we'll do the
same thing will change the state of this
guy move him down over here and add this
one and released the product the Walker
itself has three hands for grabbing the
cargoes h1 h2 and h3 and three feet for
walking f1 f2 and f3 and a fourth foot
that keeps it oriented towards the
loading station and this is a slightly
more chemical picture of that same set
of that same Walker this just shows how
the transfer takes place we have a
toehold sitting over here that attacks
h1 hydrogen bonds to over this position
and then this displaces the other rest
of it so it's over here it doesn't look
like it so well in this picture but more
hydrogen bonds are over here and over
there and forming more hydrogen bonds
provides the thermodynamic driving force
for each of these reactions we can
program this thing to make a diversity
of products depending on whether we
program these three stations to be in
the off state or the on state where
they're going to add to the locker so we
can add nothing we can add only the 5
nanometer particle only the pair of
fives or only the 10 i'm going to add
only the pair of fives and the five the
10 the 5 or the 10 the pair or what i
showed you in detail is at all three to
the locker this just shows the end of
the walk for all eight possible products
this just shows the eight possible
products and this shows tem pictures
transmission electron microscopy showing
the nanoparticles for all of these cases
and that we made a minute
case summarize what we've talked about
here with polyhedral catenate I didn't
talk about not some rum earrings we can
make them to can be assembled from
branch DNA by ligation 2d lattices with
tunable features have been made from DNA
tile I didn't talk about origami
components we've done that to 3d
crystals with two more properties been
self assembled and their structures have
been determined heterologous species
like the nanoparticle has been including
DNA nano constructs there was more that
I didn't have time to tell you
algorithmic Assembly has been prototyped
at least one of its problems has been
addressed Nana mechanical devices have
been assembled from branched DNA
including shapeshifters and walkers he's
been combined an origami surface to
produce a nanoscale assembly line a lot
of students always in the audience and I
just and often they asked me you know
what should I be studying if I'm
interested in doing this well obviously
math computer science and physics and
biophysics and crystallography and
chemistry and bio and biophysics we
didn't mention that in bio chemistry and
biology let's not all alright this is
the picture from the floor of the
Pergamon Museum in Berlin and if you
look closely this is exactly like that
first picture I showed you or I took
four branch junctions and putting
together to make a quadrilateral if you
look closely you'll see that indeed it's
a double helix or two different colors
here I didn't even have to flip the
slide they get it to be right-handed so
in addition to all the other things that
you have to learn don't forget art it's
really very useful finally I have to
thank the people who've paid for this
work over the years NIGMS onr NSF
briefly DARPA aro briefly the Keck
foundation a belly up company and do as
well is my webpage it's not quite up to
date i hoped updated this summer but you
can find out everything you need to find
out from
that so thank you very much
questions
well
yeah his course
yeah yes is the answer
can I do go to a single game of life oh
yeah that I i think that's that's
certainly possible I thought that's sort
of where we were starting where Eric was
starting in his work with the Wang tiles
in fact I mean but yeah I mean I don't
know how far we could get but it's
certainly that's possible we're working
on that as we speak that's a little hard
but we're it's it's certainly something
that we're very interested in doing
we're also very interested in getting it
supported by somebody the answer is yeah
and we're thinking of and of course in
3d those are quasi crystals so we're
very interested in doing that type of
thing yes
thank you
I'm sorry okay so that that's that's
interesting question and the answer is
it depends how you ask the question if
you're asked I mean most of what we do
virtually everything we do is done as a
in ensemble so we have a whole bunch of
molecules that we're looking at the
Walker that I showed here was analyzed
by cross-linking and you know so we
would let these things go for you in two
three four hours make sure that we got
everybody over whatever barriers were
there as best we could if you ask the
question from a single molecule
perspective it's reasonably quick but
you know that's like this one sort of
quick and the next one might be kind of
slow and it's yeah okay so I I mean
really quick would would be of the order
of seconds to getting everybody to go
over the hump would be of the order of
20 to 30 minutes anymore Bernie Bernie
urkki when in the first device he made
that was sequence-specific programmable
was and showed a curve that looked like
that where I can wear the complete
extent of the curve was something like
20 or 40 minutes I forget and ninety
percent of it was gone after about the
first hundred seconds or something and
then you were waiting
the next thousand seconds or so for the
last ten percent so you don't know you
know what one of the one of the facts of
life is we work with synthetic DNA all
this DNA is synthetic and there are some
errors occasionally in that you don't
know whether you're slow doing these
things because in fact you have to get
over a hump be caused by some error in
the deprotection of the molecule or
something like that so so the answer is
time is a hard thing to estimate in
these cases but you know reasonably
quick the I think I think we spent
probably about 3-4 hours on a per step
on the on the assembly line just to make
sure we had it all yes oh we haven't
done four legged walkers yet there there
is another system that Milan siyana
[ __ ] has done where the walkers
basically our DNA's imes that eat a
field of DNA grass effectively and they
are they are for four legged species I
believe
was the assembly your initial ultimate
goal well our initial goal was to solve
the crystallization problem you know I
mean it was obvious even back in the
late 70s early 80s that all the other
hurdles in the course of solving
three-dimensional biological structures
were a computational instrumental and
they were going to be solved relatively
soon and by other people and this was
the one problem that nobody was really
addressing in out-of-the-box way I mean
you know today mostly it's done by
robotics and whatnot but it's still
trial and error and trial and error I
find offensive so yes have you made any
no orientable surfaces like movies
I haven't made a mobius strip but one of
my former students how yen has so yeah
that's doable it's just a matter no he's
made something pretty close but it's not
quite a climb bottle not okay we could
give me another dimension I'm sure we
can do
you